well my first question that I've been
asking everybody is that obviously Mel
Brooks has had such a massive influence
on film and television all the way back
to Sid Caesar so what was your first
exposure to his work I grew up with this
uh book and album free to be you and me
and he played a baby in it and Marlo
Thomas played the other baby and they
were like talking about their gender and
he's like hi hi I'm a baby well what do
you think I am a loaf of bread like it's
like this whole thing I literally grew
up knowing this entire skit I would
imitate Marlo imitate Mel I feel like
this formed me doing like all the voices
I do for animation
um 3 000 year old man with Carl Reiner
uh Young Frankenstein high anxiety he uh
somebody asked me do you remember the
first time you saw history of the World
Part One no I don't remember because
it's just always been a part of my DNA
and my nervous system like this is the
thing that
everybody understands like Nick asked me
to play his wife in this he texted me
because we've known each other for years
and we do animation together big mouth
and human resources and he texted me do
you want to play my wife in history of
the World Part Two
um I'm sure he I was like the 25th text
like the other people were busy I don't
give a I'm so happy that it
landed on me and he texted do you want
to play my wife in history of the World
Part Two And I said Voice or face parts
and he texted back face parts and then I
said I texted him back a fungal hand
like what else am I gonna say no
Nick Kroll asks you to come over and
help him like you know clean the dog
from his backyard you are there yes
sir anything anything for Nick anything
for Mel and that's what everybody I
think the whole like Village like that
came together but the difference is it's
like it's just like it feels like a
happening it felt really really special
like rare air rare air yeah it
definitely it's someone who also grew up
with with history of the world and with
you know Spaceballs and Young
Frankenstein and everything else it
feels like it really captures that air
of all of his work and I wanted to know
you are in one of the few sketches that
sort of stretches over a sort of
multitude of episodes so and and you
know obviously a lot of that is improv a
lot of that is sort of kicking things
around but is there anything that ended
up sort of on The Cutting Room floor
that you wish sort of would have made it
in there oh I have no idea I haven't
seen it no
I haven't seen any of it I'm dying to
see it that's
fine I can tell you right now your
sketch the whole Russian Revolution
thing I think was personally my favorite
uh one in the entire show you and
nickroll are hilarious Dove Cameron's
hilarious and I spent the entire time
wondering why I knew your voice and then
I realized I grew up watching you on or
watching recess oh yes
yeah she introduced you to Madame fist
yes yeah
she's a little in there but is is yeah
she is a little bit just a tad yeah but
is there sort of any difference in in
prepping for Voice work versus something
that like this which is so sketch-based
and so sort of based on on improv
um you have to have everything at the
ready when you're doing you know this is
like a really high level of satire and
parody and when you're doing voice over
and animation and you're in a booth
um I learned years ago you've got you
can't be afraid you gotta look silly you
gotta just go for it you've got to pull
everything out of you that you have in
in your bank in your Rolodex and so it's
um
it's very it's very very similar and
it's but the the differences in a studio
you don't need to like get into hair and
makeup
um and but you know the best P the best
performers in voiceover are the ones who
have like all of that stuff inside of
them you know that's why Nick is so good
in all of those worlds well thank you so
much for talking with me today on a
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
too